rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas très on
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Bakounine
Bakounine est un philosophe politique
russe né en 1814 c'est l'un des plus
importants représentants de l'anarchisme
un courant du socialisme qui prône
l'abolition de l'État l'abolition de
toute forme d'autorité
rappelons qu'un archisme c'est Anne
harqué l'absence de commandement
l'absence de chef donc ce que combattre
les anarchistes c'est l'autorité c'est
l'agrandifférence entre les communistes
et les anarchistes et communistes sont
pour l'État pour l'autorité de l'État en
tout cas comme structure transitionnelle
entre le capitalisme et le socialisme un
état au service des travailleurs plutôt
qu'au service des propriétaires
les anarchistes quant à eux pensent
qu'il n'y a rien à attendre de bon de la
part de l'État que l'État ne peut avoir
pour effet que de maintenir la
domination que toute structure étatique
que toute structure dirigeante porte en
elle le germe de l'oppression
l'idée fondamentale des anarchistes
c'est que le pouvoir corrompt et qu'on
aura beau former des dirigeants pour
qu'ils défendent les intérêts des
travailleurs dans les faits dans la
pratique concrète du pouvoir ça se passe
pas comme ça les hommes de pouvoir ne
s'intéressent qu'au pouvoir
pas à la classe sociale que ce pouvoir
est censé défendre il y a de ce point de
vue là un réalisme anthropologique des
anarchistes à savoir l'idée que l'être
humain n'est pas un être pur
qu'il est à l'image de sa situation
matérielle et que faire partie d'une
structure dirigeante c'est être condamné
à se comporter comme un dirigeant
autrement dit à écrasé la liberté du
peuple
la liberté c'est ça le combat des
anarchistes avant même l'égalité ou
plutôt la liberté et l'égalité sont
inséparables pourquoi parce que dans une
société où les individus sont libres il
n'y a pas d'oppression et dans une
société où il n'y a pas d'oppression il
n'y a pas d'inégalité quand les
anarchistes refusent l'autorité il
refuse à la fois ce qui opprime leur
liberté et ce qui crée l'inégalité
l'inégalité entre les dominants et les
dominés
donc sur la question de la liberté et de
l'égalité
Bakounine considère qu'on a tort
d'opposer ces deux notions
vous savez dans les cours d'éducation
civique au collège quand on veut vous
expliquer la différence entre la gauche
et la droite on vous dit la gauche
défend l'égalité le socialisme et la
droite défend la liberté le libéralisme
et le sous-entendu c'est que l'un exclut
l'autre qu'il faut choisir entre la
liberté et l'égalité ou en tout cas que
le fait de favoriser l'une se fait
toujours au détriment de l'autre pour
Bakounine ça n'a pas de sens la liberté
et l'égalité ne sont pas contradictoires
elles sont complémentaires
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'au lieu
de parler d'anarchisme certains
préfèrent parler de socialisme
libertaire une expression beaucoup plus
précise conceptuellement puisqu'elle
unifie l'égalité sociale avec la liberté
individuelle
donc ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
pour Bakounine et pour les anarchistes
en général le projet politique c'est
celui d'une société libre et égalitaire
égalitaire parce que libre libre parce
qu'egalitaire c'est-à-dire une société
dans laquelle aucun groupe d'individus
n'étant position d'asservir qui que ce
soit à sa volonté et à ses intérêts
maintenant il va falloir qu'on parle de
Dieu alors là on pourrait dire mais
qu'est-ce que ça à avoir ben ce que ça à
voir c'est que pour Bakounine Dieu c'est
l'archétype ultime de l'autorité et que
pour lui il y a un continuum il y a même
un lien de causalité entre la soumission
des travailleurs à l'État capitaliste et
la soumission des travailleurs à Dieu
pour Bakounine Dieu n'est pas simplement
un objet de croyance Dieu c'est la
matrice originelle de la domination
l'organe suprême de la domination
l'autorité qui rend possible toutes les
autres autorités et la thèse de
Bakounine c'est que tant que subsistera
la croyance en Dieu
l'émancipation des travailleurs n'aura
pas lieu en d'autres termes ce qu'on va
tenter de comprendre aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi selon Bakounine la croyance en
Dieu empêche la révolution
pour comprendre ce que Bakounine
reproche à Dieu ou en tout cas ce qu'il
reproche à la croyance en Dieu on va
s'appuyer sur son livre Dieu et l'État
publié en 1882 Dieu est l'état c'est
vraiment la référence en termes de
littérature anarchiste athée et dans ce
livre Bakounine se positionne
philosophiquement par rapport à un grand
clivage qui traverse toute l'histoire de
la pensée c'est un clivage bien connu en
philosophie puisque c'est celui qui
oppose l'idéalisme au matérialisme
Bakounine et matérialiste il est
matérialiste c'est-à-dire qu'il
considère que le monde n'est constitué
que de matière que tout ce qui existe et
soit de nature matérielles cet
ordinateur cette chemise cette lampe
soit d'origine matérielle ça veut dire
quoi d'origine matérielle ça veut dire
être l'expression de phénomènes
matériels exemple la pensée c'est quoi
la pensée
c'est l'expression de l'activité du
cerveau or le cerveau ces matériels
puisque c'est un organe il ne faut pas
confondre la pensée qui est un phénomène
immatériel avec le cerveau qui est
l'origine matérielle de ce phénomène
immatériel
il ne faut pas les confondre nous dit
Bakounine mais il faut comprendre que
l'un est le produit de l'autre
qu'il n'y aurait pas de pensée son
cerveau
autrement dit que l'origine des entités
immatérielles les idées les sentiments
les valeurs c'est de la matière
c'est ça le matérialisme
l'idéalisme c'est au contraire la
conception qui consiste à dire que les
idées que les entités spirituelles pour
ainsi dire existe séparément de la
matière que certes dans notre monde
terrestre les idées sont incorporées
dans la matière
qui est déjà un pléonasme puisque
incorporé ça veut dire entrer dans un
corps entrer dans la matière donc oui
les idées ne sont pas des entités qui
flottent autour de nous elles s'incarne
elle se matérialise mais pour les
idéalistes ce n'est pas la matière qui
produit les idées ce sont les idées qui
investissent la matière
à l'époque moderne l'opposition entre
idéalisme et matérialisme c'est
l'opposition entre Hegel et Marx pour
Hegel les événements sont la
concrétisation de l'idée la
concrétisation de ce qu'il appelle la
Raison universelle
tandis que pour Marx les idées sont au
contraire la spiritualisation des
événements les événements arrivent ils
se produisent sous l'impulsion de force
matérielles et leur intelligence
c'est-à-dire leur compréhension
leur conversion en idée arrivent ensuite
pour les matérialistes ce n'est pas que
l'esprit n'existe pas c'est que l'esprit
n'existe pas en tant que réalité séparée
de la matière
l'esprit c'est l'écume de la matière
Bakounine utilise une image il dit
l'esprit c'est une fleur dont les
racines sont la matière la matière c'est
la terre c'est l'origine la fleur c'est
l'émanation aérienne c'est l'émanation
célestes de la racine
chez Bakounine ce n'est pas le ciel qui
gouverne la terre c'est la terre qui se
prolonge dans le ciel
donc entre l'idéalisme et le
matérialisme on a une totale opposition
métaphysique et d'ailleurs même le mot
métaphysique n'est pas approprié puisque
justement pour les matérialistes il y a
pas de métaphysique
puisqu'il n'y a pas de dualisme matière
esprit la métaphysique c'est quand on a
d'un côté la matière la physique donc et
d'un autre côté l'esprit ce qui est
au-delà du physique
pour les matérialistes il n'y a pas de
métaphysique puisque l'Esprit n'existe
pas indépendamment du physique
l'esprit est inclus dans le physique
ce qui fait dire à Bakounine quelque
chose d'extrêmement radical en tout cas
pour un philosophe qui est de dire la
métaphysique c'est l'autre nom de la
psychologie
traduction quand les hommes parlent
d'entité abstraite quand il parle
d'esprit d'idées d'essence il ne parle
pas de la réalité il parle de même il
projette à l'extérieur de même les
productions de leur cerveau en un mot
ils prennent leur fiction pour des
réalités
une fiction c'est une création
spirituelle de l'imagination humaine
donc la fiction n'est réelle que dans la
mesure où elle est la manifestation
d'une réalité qui est la réalité
matérielle du cerveau
et encore une fois les idées existent
mais elle n'existe qu'en tant que
production
comme quand on fait un rêve d'ailleurs
vous noterez on fait un rêve on le
produit un rêve ce n'est pas réel au
sens où ce qui se passe dans notre rêve
n'est pas réel mais le rêve est un
phénomène réel un phénomène lié à
l'activité du cerveau
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
conclusion de Bakounine la conclusion de
Bakounine c'est que de la même façon que
les idées sont des productions du
cerveau Dieu lui-même est une production
du cerveau
Dieu est une fiction
un fantasme si on revient à l'étymologie
du mot fantasme
Fantasia l'image Dieu est une image il
n'est pas une entité existant en et par
elle-même
c'est nous qui le faisons exister
et la preuve que donne Bakounine c'est
que comme par hasard dans l'histoire de
l'humanité Dieu a toujours emprunté les
caractéristiques matérielles et sociales
de son époque
ça veut dire quoi bah ça veut dire que
dans l'Antiquité la religion dominante
c'était le polythéisme
chaque nation avait son Dieu c'est Dieu
et chaque dieu était assigné à une
fonction sociale le dieu de la guerre le
dieu de l'agriculture le dieu des arts
comme si la religion épousait
parfaitement l'organisation matérielle
des hommes
bah oui c'est pas que la religion épouse
l'organisation sociale
c'est que la religion est le
prolongement spirituel de l'organisation
sociale
pendant la préhistoire avant que les
nations n'existent on avait l'animisme
l'animisme ça consistait à dire Dieu est
dans chaque chose
il est dans cette pierre dans cet arbre
dans cet animal
donc là encore les hommes de la
préhistoire avaient la religion de leur
environnement social puisque leur
environnement social c'était les
éléments naturels
même chose pour le monothéisme le
christianisme
Bakounine nous dit le monothéisme c'est
quand tous les peuples ont le même Dieu
autrement dit le monothéisme c'est la
religion des nations unifiées
unifiées par quoi par l'Empire en
l'occurrence par l'Empire romain
autrement dit si le Dieu des chrétiens
est un dieu universel le Dieu de tous
les peuples c'est parce que la
colonisation romaine a entraîné une
unification des nations
donc il fallait le même Dieu pour tout
le monde
Dieu est à l'image de ceux qui
gouvernent il est le reflet spirituel de
la situation matérielle de ce qu'il
gouverne
on a le Dieu de son imagination et on a
l'imagination de sa situation matérielle
Bakounine ne méprise pas la religion au
sens où ce qu'il cherche d'abord c'est
en comprendre les causes en tant que
matérialiste il considère que la cause
de toutes les entités idéales de toutes
les fictions c'est l'esprit humain et
l'esprit humain est le reflet des
sociétés humaines
Bakounine ne méprise pas la religion
mais il pense que le moment est venu de
s'en émanciper le moment est venu de
prendre conscience que c'est nous qui
avons inventé Dieu
parce qu'on en avait besoin parce que ça
nous rassurer parce que ça nous a permis
de traverser des épreuves comme l'enfant
qui croit à la petite souris parce que
perdre une dent mais ça fait mal
on supporte mieux la douleur quand on
donne un sens à cette douleur
Dieu est une fiction mais dans le
développement duanité ce fut une fiction
nécessaire
Bakounine a été très influencé par Eagle
puis par Marx le point commun entre Marx
et Eagle étant la dialectique la
dialectique c'est l'idée que les choses
passent par des étapes et que chaque
nouvelle étape est une négation de la
précédente
dans une vision dialectique de
l'histoire on ne dit pas qu'un événement
est bon ou mauvais on ne dit pas qu'une
croyance est vrai ou fausse on dit
qu'elle était historiquement nécessaire
qu'il fallait en passer par là parce que
c'est comme ça que le monde fonctionne
par étape successive et par
autosuppression
le jardinier ne condamne pas le bourgeon
au nom du fait qu'il préfère la fleur
il sait que le bourgeon est une étape
nécessaire du développement de la fleur
et la floraison d'un point de vue
dialectique ce sera la négation du
bourgeon
comme le papillon et la négation de la
chenille on n'arrive pas au papillon
sans être passé par la chenille on
n'arrive pas à la dernière étape avant
d'avoir parcouru toutes les étapes qui
précèdent bien pour Bakounine c'est le
même raisonnement pour la religion et
selon lui après l'animisme après le
polythéisme après le monothéisme leur
est venu de la dernière étape
l'athéisme
autrement dit la dernière étape c'est la
prise de conscience que Dieu est notre
invention
qui naît que notre invention la dernière
étape c'est l'étape du retournement de
la conscience humaine sur elle-même
qui comprend que c'est elle qui a créé
ce en quoi elle croit et qui sont
l'émancipe qui sont émancipes pour faire
advenir une humanité libre
une humanité capable de s'auto-organiser
qui n'aura plus besoin de Dieu et qui
parce qu'il n'aura plus besoin de Dieu
n'aura plus besoin de mettre
pour Bakounine Dieu est le père de
toutes les autorités
et entre l'autorité de Dieu l'autorité
du capital et l'autorité de l'État il
n'y a pas une différence de nature mais
une différence de degré
parce que dans les trois cas il s'agit
de s'en remettre à une instance qui
prétend nous dire ce qui est bon pour
nous et qui nous l'impose la critique
anarchiste de l'autorité c'est la
critique de tout ce qui part du postulat
que les êtres humains ont besoin d'être
tenus par la main qu'ils ont besoin
d'être guidés dirigés
et d'ailleurs ça va assez loin puisque
pour Bakounine même l'autorité de la
science doit être contestée par la
science en elle-même Bakounine respecte
la science il respecte tout ce qui va
dans le sens d'une compréhension
rationnelle du monde mais il rejette
l'autorité de la science
parce qu'il rejette la prétention de
toute autorité à nous indiquer la voie à
suivre si la science devait gouverner
elle se comporterait comme n'importe
quel instance de pouvoir elle
opprimerait et elle obligerait les
individus à se plier à sa volonté
mais le fait est contre l'autorité de la
science et l'autorité de Dieu c'est
l'autorité de Dieu que Bakounine combat
le plus pourquoi parce qu'elle est
absurde
logiquement absurde
et qu'est-ce qui fait que la croyance en
Dieu est absurde selon Bakounine c'est
le fait que cette croyance repose sur
une contradiction la contradiction entre
d'un côté un dieu parfait un dieu auquel
il ne manque rien et d'un autre côté le
besoin qu'a eu Dieu de créer le monde et
qui plus est un monde corrompu
un monde où le mal sévit si tu existes
quel besoin a-t-il eu de créer notre
monde
quel besoin a-t-il eu de le créer un
parfait
peut-être qu'il s'ennuyait mais s'il
s'ennuyaient c'est qu'il n'est pas
parfait
c'est ça l'absurdité fondamentale de la
croyance en Dieu
l'incohérence
l'incohérence érigée en mystère pour lui
donner plus de profondeur parce que dire
cette absurde ça oblige à cesser de
croire alors que dire c'est mystérieux
ça donne l'impression qu'il y a un
secret à dévoiler
ça donne l'impression d'appartenir à une
caste d'élus
Bakounine nous dit que les gens qui
croient en Dieu ne croient pas en lui
malgré son absurdité mais à cause de son
absurdité comme si plus une idée était
absurde plus il devenait valorisant d'y
croire
la réponse de Bakounine c'est que ce
n'est pas parce qu'une chose est absurde
qu'elle est profonde
si elle est absurde c'est peut-être tout
simplement qu'elle est stupide
mais que le reconnaître c'est
reconnaître que depuis des millénaires
nous croyons dans quelque chose de
stupide et ça c'est compliqué
mais le problème de la croyance en Dieu
ce n'est pas seulement son caractère
absurde c'est le fait que nous ayons
donné à cette absurdité un pouvoir sur
nous
c'est le fait que nous ayons donné à
Dieu les pleins pouvoirs sur nos vies
croire en Dieu c'est placé à l'intérieur
de notre conscience un surveillant un
gendarme Un gendarme auquel on délègue
le pouvoir de nous sanctionner en cas de
manquement assez lois
et comme ce gendarme est omniscient on
peut rien lui cacher
il a les clés de notre conscience
raison pour laquelle on est contraint de
lui obéir
on peut aussi faire le lien avec Freud
pour Freud l'homme a inventé Dieu parce
qu'il avait besoin de réponse des
réponses aux grandes énigmes de
l'univers
l'origine du monde le sens de
l'existence la vie après la mort
l'invention de Dieu par l'homme répond
d'abord un besoin de sécurité psychique
un besoin d'apaiser notre angoisse
très bien mais sauf qu'en voulant
apaiser notre angoisse nous avons créé
la névrose le conflit intérieur le
conflit entre la loi divine et le désir
est entendu qu'on ne peut pas supprimer
le désir on ne peut que le contenir
le réprimer
et réprimer le désir c'est créer une
tension intérieure une tension qui
lorsqu'on en est conscient génère la
culpabilité
Dieu aime les hommes mais les hommes
craignent Dieu et ce que l'on craint on
s'y soumet
la croyance en Dieu va donc de père avec
l'infériorisation de l'homme ce que
Bakounine résume en disant que si Dieu
est tout l'homme n'est rien si Dieu est
le maître l'homme et son esclave
on peut pas sortir de ça
en clair si Bakounine rejette la
croyance en Dieu c'est parce que la
croyance en Dieu maintient les hommes
dans la soumission aveugle à l'autorité
elle les maintient dans l'idée que nous
avons besoin d'une autorité pour nous
guider
elle nous maintient dans la peur de la
liberté pour Bakounine combattre Dieu
ses combattre la fiction qui nous
enchaîne
donc vous l'aurez compris Bakounine
n'est pas croyant
et pourtant ça ne l'empêche pas de
rendre hommage un personnage de la Bible
ce personnage c'est Satan
alors évidemment il y a quelque chose de
provocateur dans le fait de rendre
hommage à Satan surtout au XIXe siècle à
une époque où l'Église encore une forte
influence mais si Bakounine fait l'éloge
de Satan c'est parce que Satan est un
emblème
l'emblème de la révolte
Satan c'est celui qui s'est révolté
contre Dieu c'est celui qui a refusé de
se soumettre et c'est surtout celui qui
a donné à l'homme l'accès à la
connaissance
c'est l'épisode du jardin d'Eden le
fruit défendu et le fruit défendu c'est
le fruit de l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal quand Satan
s'introduit dans le jardin d'Eden sous
la figure du serpent il dit à Adam et
Eve si vous goûtez ce fruit vous serez
comme Dieu vous connaîtrez le bien et le
mal
or Dieu ne voulait pas à Caden et Ève et
cette connaissance il voulait les
maintenir dans l'ignorance et ce que dit
Bakounine c'est que c'est exactement ce
que font les gouvernements ils cherchent
à maintenir le peuple dans l'ignorance
parce qu'un peuple ignorant est beaucoup
plus facile à dominer
et c'est ça finalement qui fait le lien
entre la religion et la politique entre
Dieu et l'État l'ignorance la nécessité
de l'ignorance
parce que l'ignorance engendre la
soumission parce que la connaissance
engendre l'insoumission
Satan et l'émancipateur du genre humain
parce que Satan a appris à l'homme la
désobéissance or pour Bakounine c'est ça
qui définit l'être humain la capacité à
désobéir la capacité à se révolter grâce
à la pensée la pensée rend autonome
l'ignorance rend dépendant
et donc le but de l'État c'est de mettre
le peuple sous tutelle c'est de
l'infantiliser pour pouvoir se placer en
instituteur parce qu'on obéit d'autant
plus facilement qu'on a été habitué à
obéir
on obéit d'autant plus facilement que
l'obéissance est devenue pour nous une
seconde nature
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a chez
Bakounine l'idée que la religion et la
matrice de toutes les soumissions parce
qu'une obéissance en entraîne une autre
parce que si on est habitué à obéir à
l'Être suprême on peut s'habituer à
obéir à l'état et c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé au moment de la
Révolution française
le culte de l'Être suprême ce n'était
pas le culte de Dieu c'était le culte de
l'État le culte du bien commun dont
l'État était censé être la
concrétisation
autant les révolutionnaires ont combattu
la religion chrétienne autant ils ont
instauré à sa place la religion civile
un culte pour en remplacer un autre mais
l'effet est exactement le même la
servissement du peuple a un idéal
que cette idéal s'appelle Dieu ou qu'il
s'appelle l'état fondamentalement ça
change rien
ça reste une fiction
ça reste une fiction mais dont la
conséquence est une soumission bien
réelle
répétons ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
si Dieu est tout l'homme n'est rien
puisqu'il ne peut rien y avoir en dehors
du tout
de la même façon si l'État est tout
l'homme n'est rien
face à un idéal l'homme s'efface il
devient néant
la mécanique de la soumission c'est la
mécanique de la néantisation
non pas au sens où Sartre disait que
l'homme était néant puisque pour Sartre
être né en signifiait être absolument
libre non là on parle de néant au sens
d'absence de valeur
d'absence de dignité au sens de
déshumanisation
l'idéalisme c'est ce qui justifie que
des individus meurent sur l'hôtel de
l'idéal un idéal on lutte pour lui on se
sacrifie pour lui et écoutez bien ce mot
sacrifier
détruire au nom du sacré
le sacré implique la destruction de ce
qui le nid
et ça c'est totalement indépendant de ce
que prône le sacré en question
c'est totalement indépendant de la
nature de l'idéal en question
c'est l'idéal lui-même qui mène à ça
au nom d'un idéal religieux on peut bien
se permettre d'envoyer quelques
infidèles au bûcher au nom d'un idéal
politique on peut bien se permettre
d'envoyer quelques dissidents dans des
camps
et oh non de l'idéal scientifique on
peut bien se permettre de dicter aux
individus ce qu'ils doivent penser
et c'est ce qui permet de comprendre
cette phrase de Bakounine toute
idéalisme conduit à l'esclavage
toute idéalisme conduit à l'esclavage
parce que toute idéalisme repose sur
l'idée qu'il existerait quelque chose de
supérieur à la matière
ce qui définit l'idéalisme c'est la
soumission à une transcendance
c'est quand les instructions viennent
d'en haut
l'idéalisme part du haut et va vers le
bas le matérialisme par du bas et va
vers le haut
voilà pourquoi l'anarchisme est une
conséquence du matérialisme une
conséquence de l'idée qui n'existe rien
en haut tout ce qui existe vient d'en
bas de la matière des individus
l'anarchisme c'est quand les
instructions viennent d'en bas ou plutôt
quand il n'y a plus d'instructions
précisément parce qu'il n'y a plus
d'autorité pour donner les instructions
pour Bakounine il est dans l'essence
même de toute idéalisme de devenir une
religion une religion dans laquelle Dieu
est remplacé par un idéal par l'État par
le capitalisme par la science
une religion qui comme toute religion
cherchera à s'imposer aux hommes de
manière dogmatique autoritaire élitiste
une religion qui même si elle prône la
raison tue la raison en l'homme
puisqu'elle l'invite à croire qu'il
existe un idéal auquel il serait
légitime de se soumettre
il y a un dernier aspect de l'idéalisme
que Bakounine évoque et qu'il appelle
l'abstraction
l'abstraction c'est la transformation de
l'être humain en idée en concept vous
savez comme quand on dit l'homme a fait
ceci l'homme a fait cela l'homme a
construit les pyramides l'homme a marché
sur la lune mais sauf que l'homme ça
veut rien dire
l'homme vous ne le croiserez jamais dans
la rue
à proprement parler l'homme n'existe pas
c'est une abstraction ce qui existe ce
sont des individus des individus
concrets et dire l'homme dire le genre
humain c'est faire un premier pas vers
la réification des individus vers la
négation de leur humanité
ce n'est pas l'homme qui a construit les
pyramides ce sont des hommes des hommes
qui ont été exploités par d'autres
hommes lesquels ont alors pu se
prévaloir d'avoir fait ce que d'autres
avaient fait
l'abstraction permet l'appropriation
l'abstraction permet de dire qu'on a
fait ce que d'autres que nous on fait et
donc pour Bakounine l'abstraction n'est
pas simplement un abus de langage
c'est un instrument d'oppression
un instrument de légitimation de
l'exploitation
parce que l'abstraction a pour effet de
dissimuler la relation dominante dominée
je vous fais travailler 14 heures par
jour mais enfin nous faisons partie de
la même famille la famille humaine
c'est vous qui faites tout c'est vous
qui usez votre corps à mon bénéfice mais
comme je vous ai vendu le concept de
genre humain vous n'avez pas
l'impression de travailler pour moi vous
travaillez pour le genre humain
nous travaillons tous pour le genre
humain
c'est ça la finalité de l'abstraction la
dissimulation des rapports concrets
le recouvrement de la réalité concrète
donc ce n'est pas simplement un problème
de mots c'est un problème d'altération
de la réalité
et d'altération de la conscience de la
réalité
à chaque fois qu'il emploie le mot homme
le travailleur devient le propagandiste
de sa propre exploitation
il se voit la réalité de sa propre
condition
il vit dans ce que Marx s'appelait la
fausse conscience
pour Bakounine être matérialiste ce
n'est donc pas seulement nier
l'existence des entités spirituelles ce
n'est pas simplement une position
métaphysique c'est une position
politique
parce que c'est refusé de reconnaître
les abstractions comme des catégories
valides
c'est refuser de considérer comme valide
des catégories qui ont pour but de
dissimuler les rapports d'exploitation
réels
en résumé être matérialiste c'est faire
primer la réalité humaine sur n'importe
quel abstraction et sur n'importe quel
idéal
je cite
si Dieu est l'homme est esclave or
l'homme peut doit être libre donc Dieu
n'existe pas je défie qui que ce soit de
sortir de ce cercle et maintenant qu'on
choisisse est-il besoin de rappeler
combien et comment les religions
abétissent et corrompent les peuples
elle tue en eux la raison ce principal
instrument de l'émancipation humaine et
les réduisent à l’imbécillité conditions
essentielles de leur esclavage elle
déshonore le travail humain et en font
un signe et une source de servitude elle
tue la notion et le sentiment de la
justice humaine dans leur sein faisant
toujours pencher la balance du côté des
coquins triomphants objets privilégié de
la grâce divine elle tue l'humaine
fierté et l'humaine dignité ne
protégeant que les rampants et les
humbles elles étouffent dans le cœur des
peuples tout sentiment du même
fraternité en le remplissant de divines
cruauté toutes les religions sont
cruelles toutes sont fondées sur le sang
car tout repose principalement sur
l'idée du sacrifice c'est-à-dire sur
l'immolation perpétuelle de l'humanité à
l'inextinguible vengeance de la divinité
dans ce sanglant mystère l'homme est
toujours la victime et le prêtre homme
aussi mais homme privilégié par la grâce
et le divin bourreau cela nous explique
pourquoi les prêtres de toutes les
religions les meilleures les plus
humains les plus doux ont presque
toujours dans le fond de leur cœur et
sinon dans le cœur dans leur imagination
dans l'esprit quelque chose de cruel et
de sanguinaire tout cela nos illustres
idéalistes contemporains le savent mieux
que personne ce sont des hommes savants
qui savent leur histoire par cœur et
comme ils sont en même temps des hommes
vivants de grandes âmes pénétrées d'un
amour sincère et profond pour le bien de
l'humanité ils ont maudit et flétri tous
ces méfaits tous ces crimes de la
religion
mais esclaves mais s'il est esclave il
n'y a pour lui ni justice ni égalité ni
fraternité ni prospérité possible ils
auront beau contrairement au bon sens et
à toutes les expériences de l'histoire
se représentaient leur Dieu animés du
plus tendre amour pour la liberté
humaine un être quoi qu'il fasse ces
quelques libérales qu'il veuillent se
montrer n'en reste pas moins toujours un
mètre et son existence implique
nécessairement l'esclavage de tout ce
qui se trouve au-dessous de lui donc si
Dieu existait il n'y aurait pour lui
qu'un seul moyen de servir la liberté
humaine ce serait de cesser d'exister
nous acceptons toutes les autorités
naturelles et toutes les influences de
fait aucune de droit car toute autorité
ou toute influence de droit et comme tel
officiellement imposée devenant aussitôt
une oppression et un mensonge nous
imposerait infailliblement comme je
crois l'avoir suffisamment démontré
et l'absurdité en un mot nous repoussons
toutes législation tout autorité et
toute influence privilégiée pas tentée
officielle et légales même sorti du
suffrage universel convaincu qu'elle ne
pourront tourner jamais qu'au profit
d'une minorité dominante et exploitante
contre les intérêts de l'immense
majorité à servi voilà dans quel sens
nous sommes réellement des anarchistes
les idéalistes modernes entendent
l'autorité d'une manière tout à fait
différente quoi que libre des
superstitions traditionnelles de toutes
les religions positives existantes ils
attachent néanmoins à cette idée de
l'autorité un sens divin absolu cette
autorité n'est point celle d'une vérité
miraculeusement révélée ni celle d'une
vérité rigoureusement et
scientifiquement démontrée ils la fonde
sur un peu d'argumentation quasi
philosophique et sur beaucoup de fois
vaguement religieuses sur beaucoup de
sentiments idéalement ABS traitement
poétique leur religion est comme un
dernier essai de la divinisation de tout
ce qui constitue l'humanité dans les
hommes c'est tout le contraire de
l'oeuvre que nous accomplissons nous
croyons de voir en vue de la liberté
humaine de la dignité humaine et de la
prospérité humaine reprendre au ciel les
biens qu'il a dérobé à la terre pour les
rendre à la terre tandis que ces forçons
de commettre un dernier larcin
religieusement héroïque il voudrait eux
au contraire restituer de nouveaux au
ciel à ce divin voleur aujourd'hui
démasqué mis à son tour au pillage par
l’impiété audacieuse et par l'analyse
scientifique des libres penseurs tout ce
que l'humanité contient de plus grand de
plus beau de plus noble
le pouvoir ce n'est pas seulement la
force qui ne contraint
c'est également ce qui en nous rend
possible cette contrainte
notre acceptation
notre docilité
or la docilité n'est pas seulement une
affaire de tempérament
c'est également une affaire de croyance
si vous croyez qu'il existe une autorité
qui a la légitimité de vous dicter ce
que vous devez faire le problème ne
vient pas de votre obéissance mais de
votre croyance
votre obéissance par de votre croyance
voilà pourquoi pour Bakounine il faut
extirper en nous la croyance
extirper en nous les idoles et les
idéaux
opérées un renversement des valeurs et
ne plus situer les valeurs dans le ciel
des idées
mais dans la terre des hommes
des hommes capables de comprendre qu'ils
sont les seuls maître à bord les seuls
maîtres de leur existence
qu'ils sont libres
mais que dans un monde régie par
l'exploitation
la liberté ne s'obtient qu'au prix de la
révolte
la liberté ne se réclame pas
elle se prend
je vous remercie
[Musique]